Jean Jacques de palace 55 ans je suis
médecin psychiatre installé à Toulon et
je suis adhérent au modem depuis 2004 à
moi j'ai beaucoup j'ai beaucoup fait
dans la dans la société étudiant quand
j'étais jeune avec les corpus à
Marseille j'ai fait des études de
médecine les mutuelles étudiantes etc et
puis en 2003 2004 après le discours de
Bayrou de Toulouse j'ai décidé d'adhérer
au Mouvement Démocrate je suis élu à
Toulon au conseil municipal de Toulon
qui est sous les feux de la de la rampe
actuellement avec la démission du maire
par les juges c'est le troisième c'est
le troisième mer sur 4 qui est condamné
à Toulon depuis 1959
et on a une particularité c'est que on a
eu le troisième le troisième président
du conseil général sur quatre qui a été
inculpé aussi
on est dans le cadre d'une liste d'union
avec les amis d'en marche et les autres
démocrates et les centristes du Var donc
on est dans l'opposition
à l'ancien maire uber Falcon c'est le
discours de Toulouse qui m'a déclenché
quand j'ai entendu François Bayrou
allait tout seul devant tout le monde et
dire que si on pensait tous la même
chose c'est compenser plus rien et tout
est fait pour organiser un accueil
chaleureux à défaut d'être toujours
sincère à celui qui vient pourtant
dénoncer l'hégémonisme d'un parti unique
réuni derrière un seul homme si nous
pensons tous la même chose c'est que
nous ne pensons plus rien alors il y a
des lieux
ça m'a fait un électrochoc c'est
exactement ce que je pensais de ce du
rassemblement de l'UMP de l'époque
[Musique]